And now to you scoutmasters.
At camp, while I served on staff there, the cook was always
the one that got chosen first for any of the baseball games when we made
up teams. You know why? He always made the best batter.
Ouch. Ouch. Hey.
This is podcast number 101.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green. So all
your letters of protest and complaints about the joke is just heard.
I will forward to Bill McFarlane, who contributed it to the Scoutmaster
podcast. Thank you, Bill. In the mailbag this week. It's a
big mailbag this week. And so here we go.
Will Hensman wrote in to say, Happy 100th,
Clark. Can't wait for more. Great. Top 10. I'm guilty of at least seven
out of 10. And that goes back to most of
these messages. Go Back to our 100th podcast last week, and we
started out with the top 10 reasons.
You may be listening to the Scoutmaster podcast
a little too much. So you might want to go back and
hear that. If you haven't heard that, let's see. Howard Jones
from Troop 570 in West Springfield, Massachusetts,
said, What a great milestone. 100 podcasts. Congrats. You seem to
be channeling a mix of Gene shepherd and Green Bar Bill.
Well, geez, Howard, that's a nice thing to say.
Oh, about retelling your jokes around a campfire? I need to
be clear. I didn't tell the penguin joke. I look forward to
the next 100. All the best. And we're not going to even discuss the penguin
joke again, are we? Boy, you got to go
back a ways for that. So, Howard, thanks for being a longtime listener.
Larry Geiger said, Happy 100th Clark. I love the music.
So much fun. More Maynard Ferguson, please. Well,
Larry, you'll be happy with this podcast then. And you're all going to hear Larry
in a little while. Peter LaRue, my buddy from
over in South Africa, said, congratulations, Clark. I look forward to many
more podcasts. Steve Borger from Melrose Troop
68, who has a podcast himself, said, Congratulations on
podcast 100. Jeff Pearson said,
Congratulations on number 100. I have enjoyed them all
and look forward to many more. The Netcomish now, if you're
not familiar with their website, it's the USSSP
website that is the United States
Scouting Service Project website. Said,
I just put a recommendation out to our Facebook readers to have
a listen to your podcast. Well, thank you so much. Adam Cox wrote in
and said, congratulations. I've downloaded podcast number
100 for my trip home tomorrow. Blaise Vitali
wrote in. Congratulations. I've gotten lots of great advice from these podcasts. I scored
four of your top 10 signs.
Brian Spellman said. Congrats. Been listening since the
start. Keep them coming. And Brian is one of the presenters for
Scout Nation Podcast. He also has a blog
out there and Brian's out there in Indiana if I
remember correctly. Thanks, Brian. Kyle Ryle got in touch and he
said, keep those great podcasts coming. Clark, I've recommended your site and podcast to
many scouters in my area. Hope some of it rubs off.
Folks, if you do have a problem with podcasts rubbing off on
anything, just use a stiff wire brush and maybe a little diluted
muriatic acid to remove any residue.
But yeah, seriously. Now the
remainder of podcast number 101 is taken up with a
Scoutmaster panel discussion and we're going to be discussing Scoutmaster conferences and
then we're going to move on to a new calling question about
how do you maintain the integrity of youth leadership while
making sure that things actually get done? That is
one of the perennial questions in scouting, isn't it? I hope we'll be able
to come up with some good advice for you. So that's going to fill the
rest of the podcast. It was a long Scoutmaster panel
discussion this time, so this is a extra
long podcast. I hope you'll enjoy it. And it's going
to be all that much longer if I don't get things started. So let's get
started, shall we? A Scout is trustworthy, loyal, helpful, friendly,
courteous, kind, obedient, cheerful, thrifty, brave, clean and reverent.
A Scout is trustworthy, oil, helpful, friendly, courteous, kind,
obedient, cheerful, thrifty, brave, clean.
Time for another Scoutmaster panel discussion. Join us as a
team of experienced veteran Scoutmasters weigh in
on your important questions.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster panel discussion.
And hey, we've got the same lineup. We've got the great team assembled here.
We've got Tom Gillard, who's down in Tullahoma,
Tennessee. How you doing, Tom? Very good. How are y'? All? Oh, doing great.
And Larry Geiger is down there in Viera, Florida.
Hey, Larry. Happy New Year, Clark. Walter Underwood's out there in
Santa Clara, California, overlooking the Silicon Valley. I understand.
How you doing, Walter? Doing good. It's enough sunset here.
The first thing I was curious about, we just got finished going
through rechartering and we did the journey to Excellence. I was just
curious about the units that you guys are involved with.
Did you guys look at the journey to excellence thing yet. This is Tom.
Yes, we've looked at it and planned to
participate in it and we're a march unit, so we've
still got a little bit of time to finish that up. My committee
is working on it, the committee chairman, but I haven't been involved with
it. My committee chair and scoutmaster are looking at it.
I did look over it when it first came out and I really like the,
the achievements on it and I expect we'll be at the gold
level for my quick tally. Yeah,
we actually struck out. We struck out totally.
We're nothing. We didn't even make the bronze level.
But you know, what it was principally is that we have so many
adults on the charter who are not fully trained that
that's what really tipped it for us. We had very soft
membership numbers this past year, but the fact that we
had a lot of legacy adults on the charter
without training is what really knocked it off for
us. Well, just a heads up there, Clark. Our council is prototyping
the new charter process and sometime in the
future, national is going to require every leader to be trained for their
position. And our council's already doing that well,
but they're also adding the college reserve position so you don't have
to register your college guys as ASNs.
Last year when the mandatory youth protection training
was instituted, we had 60 adults on our charter and
it was mostly people who had been involved at one time who wanted to keep
involved with the troop. And they just recharted habitually from year to year and then
we ended up with about 40 this year. But we're looking at establish alumni
association asking people to become a member of that. You know, these were
people who had absolutely no interchange with the troop basically
throughout the year. They just wanted to stay associated with it.
Now, like we've got some that are like yours. They, they want to be registered.
They were in the troop years ago, but we don't. We see
them once a year when they hand us a check. And would
they be better off to go through the district if that's the, the case with
this training stuff? They. I don't know.
I really don't know. I don't know the answer to that, Tom. Anybody else got
any ideas about that? Well, the district people are going to have to be trained
too. Yes. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. No, I like the idea
of an alumni, you know, scout network, some kind of thing where
you can stay in touch as kind of a Scout friend without
being an official with a registered leader.
Yeah, I'M very supportive of the idea of the mandatory training
requirement that's been rumored for a long time.
I'm definitely supportive of the idea of the youth protection training being mandatory.
It's just like I said two years ago, 60 adults.
This year, 40. This coming year. It will be a much more
realistic number. I mean, It'll be around 15 or 20. The committee is already working
on getting them trained and making sure that we have everything
ready to go when we get ready to do this journey to excellence next
time. We're pretty young troops. These troops that have been around forever. I can see
that's going to be a problem down. And I'm not just talking about Scouts that
have moved on, but you have adults that stay registered, but they're
not really active. I like the college registration
instead of the assistant Scoutmaster because that that puts
them where they really need to be. That was a real good idea. That helped
us with about four or five guys. The first of the year has come and
gone. And that means that there's been a couple of changes
to the advancement materials that we work with. And Walter,
you work with your district on Eagle Scouts. What's changed about Eagle
Scout stuff? Well, we have a one word change to the requirement
for the project, which now requires a proposal rather than a plan to
be approved. And the definition of a proposal or the details
of proposal are laid out in the new also require workbook,
which is really, I think, much easier for gives a lot more guidance to the
candidate. The Advancement resources page@scouting.org has both the new
guide to advancement and the new Eagle Project workbook.
And of course you always use the latest Eagle application. So all that is
there. We'll point everybody to that. If you go to scoutmastercg.com and
you find the post that contains this podcast, it'll have a link to the page
that we're mentioning here. Have you actually approved a
project using the new book yet? I will be doing one this
Saturday. We had two Scouts that
are getting ready to. We're getting ready to proposed their work,
their project. And I went ahead in November and
shifted them to the new workbook because I knew they weren't going to start it
till this year anyway. It's pretty straightforward because it
is a proposal. They still have to understand what they're going to be doing,
but it seems to be a little easier for the district to put their blessing
on it. I think it is. I also used it
to explain to another Scout the kind of things of detail that's
expected for A plan, because they still have to do a plan. The planning is
part of their leadership and that's evaluated by the EGLE board, which is proper.
But looking at the new one, it was much easier for him to see
what he needed to write down in the old one.
Yeah, it gives spaces for just. For lots and lots of information.
Let me just make sure I've got it. The new guide to Advancement.
What's in that now is in effect officially.
The new Eagle Project workbook is now
what you must use for any projects
that get proposed from this point on. Walter, did I understand that there's a
new application too? Yeah, so actually the new application,
I'm sure, has the new wording for requirement five, which is what would be different.
That's our best understanding. Remember, none of us are spokesman for the
bsa. That's just our best understanding. But we'll have a link to the
official website where you can get a look
at this too. One of the things that I get a lot of questions about,
and we have lots of discussions about him. One of the things that's been clarified
in the new guide to advancement is the Scoutmasters
Conference. And I thought it would be interesting just to talk a little bit about
that. I think a successful Scoutmasters Conference is reasonably easy to
understand. You sit down with a Scout just.
It's just a real good way to get to know who they are and to
see how the program is affecting them. Is there anything
that you guys have used as far as what you speak with a Scout
about and the kind of the tenor of the conversation? You hit
it pretty close to the way I do it. Just use it as a time
to, like you say, to get to know them and for them to know you.
And it shouldn't be a scary thing for them.
I think one of the important things is that it's a time for
an adult to listen to them seriously. So, you know, you need to
really listen and it's your big chance
to find out how things are going for that Scout. I also use it
as a time for. To make sure that there's some kind. Some bits of orientation,
like, you know, if for a Scout, for a new Scout,
you know, here's how boards review work, here's how
the ranks work. And then especially for someone
who's finishing up first class, I ask them what they want to
do to help the troop, what kind of things do they like to do?
And they've got all the basic Scout skills now they're
ready. I always ask Scouts, I kind of get little things
going. For instance, one thing I always do is I ask them to pick out
two things they've done in the last week or two that illustrate the Scout
oath or the Scout law. People say conferences should be real short,
like 10 minutes. I've never had a 10 minute conference. I've never had one
less than 20 minutes. And we just sit around and chat.
Even maybe Tenderfoot, I've had some almost that short.
Well, do y' all treat Scoutmaster
conferences as a one time thing or do you have multiples,
like little tweaks between main
steps, main ranks?
It's not an official for a rank, but it's just a
little course correction conference. Y' all do that?
Yeah, I end up doing that. Especially with guys in positions
of responsibility as a matter of course, we discuss things.
But then every once in a while, if there's a care or
concern that I have about the way things are going or, and I'm
trying to get better at this, if they've done something that I think is particularly
laudable and I want to congratulate them on that, I try and
take that a couple of minutes. I never put up a flag
that says this is a Scoutmasters conference.
They're kind of stealth conferences. Right,
right. Just sort of a spur of the moment thing. One of my more interesting
Scoutmaster conferences happened just a couple of months ago. I had
a Scout who'd been in the troop for several months and
was ready to do his Tenderfoot Scoutmaster conference.
And he came to the Scoutmasters conference. He had his handbook
and he had a hunk of rope and he had a pocket knife and a
compass and a map and a whole bunch of stuff. And I
didn't. I know, and I didn't really say anything.
I just kind of said one of the things that I
always like to ask, especially of the newer boys, is I said, what's your favorite
subject in school? And that kind of gives me an idea of what's going on
in their head. And so we talked for a little while and I said,
you know, my last question is usually, do you have any questions
for me? I asked him that. I said, do you have any questions for me?
He said, no, I don't think so. And I said, well, we're done. By the
way, I don't know if you understood it, but once
somebody has signed a requirement off in your book, you know, we expect that,
you know, the skill and we're not necessarily going to retest
you on it at a Scoutmasters conference. I said, does that make this
whole thing a little bit easier. And he
was quite pleased at that point. The new guide to advancement is very
clear that you cannot pass or fail a conference. You talk
to a Scout, that's a conference. Yeah. That takes a lot of pressure off of
everybody, doesn't it? I really do enjoy Scoutmaster conferences.
I enjoy sitting and talking with boys. I don't know how much they enjoy it.
Well, it never said pass or fail before. Did was
just the fact that some Scoutmasters treated it as a
pass or fail. Is that where all this came from? I think it was a
pretty common misconception from questions that I get. And I think sometimes
Scout leaders use the fact that they need to put a signature
in the book as a way to hold a boy back or
to deny him moving forward. Well, it's been the
whole thing about the quality, I'll put that in quotes, of the Scouting
instruction. If the first aid requirement isn't
as well learned as an adult EMT specialist,
then we haven't done our job. And that's just not the point.
But some adults can't let go of
that. But that's not what we're there for. I mean, a lot of people are
used to this kind of way that
school works, where you hand in an assignment
and you get graded on it or you have a test or something like that,
and everything gets quantified. And one
group that sometimes doesn't make real good Scout leaders is teachers because they
have a hard time letting go of that. Scouting is just different that way.
It's like, I guess Clark said before, they always default
to the adult, and it's hard for them to get outside
the box because of the adults, sometimes to do
their own thinking. Well, my sense when I was speaking with the guys who had
worked on the advancement God was that this was a pretty
perennial difficulty in talking with people all over the country.
One of the common threads through every single panel discussion we've had
is that, you know, whether you're in Pennsylvania or
Florida or Tennessee or. Where the heck are
you up, Walter? I'm sorry,
California. There's not
a whole lot of difference. The weather might be a little different, but what we're
doing is we're all experiencing a lot of the same stuff. Now, I asked
my guys skill things, and I asked him requirements from Tenderfoot second
class and first class, but it's pretty clear in the troop Tenderfoot
Scout doesn't know it. It's not his fault.
Because over and over again I asked the Scouts who's Responsible
for Tenderfoot second class and first class requirements,
advancement. And all the older Scouts look at me and roll their eyes and
say, we are. And then I ask them, who's responsible for star
life and eagle advancement. They roll their eyes again and go, we are again.
We're responsible for everything. You know, they get that kind of
attitude after a while. But if the Scout doesn't know his first aid,
it's not his fault. It's the patrol leader and instructor,
and it's their fault. And after a while, they. They start
to get the message. But if I go to the
SPL and say, hey, I had a kid. He didn't know, and I usually won't
say what his name is. I'll just say he wasn't real sure about this hypothermia,
hyperthermia, or whatever business. Maybe you want to. I do something similar,
Larry, because I usually pick out a requirement out
of whichever rank I'm doing a conference for. I ask
a little bit about that requirement, and then if he doesn't know
it, I note whoever signed him off on that.
And then I go to them and I have a little discussion with them.
I say, you know, he wasn't very clear about this. Maybe he was when you
signed him off. And that tends to keep them all on their
toes as well. Well, I tell the Scout, I say, if you don't know how
to tie this knot. I said, well, how would you resolve
that? You know, it said in your requirement, you know,
that he's like, well, maybe I, you know, Edge, maybe I need to,
you know, I've been instructed. Maybe I need to go practice somewhere. Okay,
there we go. So, you know, then he takes responsibility for
it. Right. Well, do you know the lead
teach and inspire during Scoutmaster
conference? I'll ask them what their job in the troop is, and they'll say,
oh, I'm quartermaster. I said, no. Oh, what's your job?
I'm quartermaster. And, you know, about the third time,
they. They realize that there's something else. And I
go, it's three words. And they go, oh, oh. And they lead.
And I said, right. So, you know, that's their job.
That other thing is their position. So I'm trying to
get that through to them also. Let me ask you this just as
a closing question. Has anybody here ever turned a boy away from a scoutmasters
conference and said that you before can sign this off? No, I need you
to do thus. And so probably three or four times out of hundreds of
conferences for Tenderfoot, I've had The guys,
if they didn't know their oath in law, they didn't have it memorized.
Then I asked them if they'd come back next week and get it right.
And I've never had a scout in the past that didn't come back with it
right. I've done the same thing and it's never or
never turned them away totally for anything. I've never
turned anyone away for a conference, though.
We had a serious conference with a scout myself and ASM about
who had really hadn't done anything in his position. And so
we talked about that and worked harder on his next
position and we had another conference, but I mean, I would have signed for either
of those. We had the conference. It was the position he didn't do.
Whenever I have asked to continue a
Scoutmasters conference, it's not that, you know, oh, you failed this
one. We'll start again someday. It's, hey, you know, there's a
couple things to address here and we'll continue as soon as you've taken care of
them. And let's make sure you know where the resources
are to take care of that, what you need to do and,
and everything. So it's usually a pretty easy going kind
of thing and it shouldn't make a Scout feel put upon or feel
bad about what they're doing, but it's an encouragement just to get whatever
loose ends need to be tied up tied up now. You know, I've always had
the guys have uniforms. I don't know that I would ever turn a scout away
that doesn't have a full uniform. You know, some guys don't, but if
they have a uniform and they don't wear it when they know that
they have a conference or a board, I'm struggling with that one just a
little bit. It hasn't come up yet. So this
is my interpretation. There's some things in the guide that are aimed at preventing
people from torturing Scouts. You know, you may have a way
of doing things that's not being obstructionist or difficult,
probably just totally in line with the philosophy behind everything.
I think that the wording now is very distinct
about things like requiring a uniform.
I think if you look at it very, if you just read what it says,
what you walk away with is, okay, you know,
we're just not going to make a federal case out of things like
this anymore. We're going to, we're going to work on the
positive end of things. And that's what you're already doing.
But some of this new Language may be a little unsettling that way.
I read it, as you know, our responsibility is
to help them achieve these things and not to stand in the way. And I
don't know how many times I've seen our SPL loan a belt
to a Scout that's about to go into a board of review.
Well, we've getting back to Larry's,
like, the Scout has a uniform. You know, he does and he
wants a board of review. And you, we have asked, well, can you,
can we do this next week when you can come in uniform? And he goes,
sure, you work with them and if
they can be in uniform, that's good and they know they should
be. Yeah, I think if you go over to ask Andy and you go through
his columns or you look at my email inbox, some days people involved
in scouting out there just have got the wrong end of the stick on some
of this stuff. And that's why I
welcome some of the statements in
the new guide to advancement so heartily, is because hopefully
over time it'll prevent people from being that way.
So joining us on the Scoutmaster podcast is Andre
Crawford. And Andre is an assistant ScoutMaster with Troop 234
in Hiker Heights, Texas. How you doing, Andre? I'm doing well,
sir. Here's my question. Maintaining the boy led,
boy run, adult supervised concept.
How can we as leaders ensure that we're
close enough to what's going on to make
sure that things are being properly planned
and thought out, but still far
enough with drawn that the boys are actually making the plans and
decisions for themselves? And I think when I first joined
the troop, I'm about a year in, so I'm still getting my feet wet.
And it's a whole other world from Cub Scouting. How can
I know where to be with relationship to what's going
on so that I can make sure things are being done correctly? Not just me,
but the other leaders, but at the same time still be far enough away to
maintain that, that boy led concept. Give me an example of something that
didn't go well. We had, we have way here, Texas, in our
area. We have the Highland game and it's a huge event.
There's troops from everywhere and you
ever seen a four hour breakfast?
I've been to many of them.
You know, they missed, they missed the first two hours of the games
because, you know, instead of there being a cook and
someone on taper duty and everyone else doing either hygiene or
airing out their tents, you had eight boys at every
checkbox. Okay. It was Absolute.
You know, those. Those plans weren't put into place. There weren't
any assignments made. You're doing this, you're doing that. We have to
be done by this time. There was no sign schedule, and it was absolute
chaos the entire week. Yeah. Okay. And that's good.
That's really, really good. Sorry. But the
question is. The question is, is how did they feel about that?
Did they feel motivated by missing part of
that? No. Okay.
No, they really didn't. Okay. So that's
a problem in your mind, but not in their mind. Your troop may just not
want to do that stuff, because once you're walking
behind them and they're going somewhere, you'll know that
you're on that path. You'll see it right in front of you.
It'll just happen. They'll all blossom.
They'll take that path and they'll go backpacking or canoeing,
or they'll go to one of these events and it'll just happen. You will
know. Maybe they like spending four hours on breakfast.
Well, yeah, maybe they had a good time and they want to do that again.
It could be hard to watch the second time or the third time.
I noticed you said something about getting them set up for success,
but that's not. That's not how I think of it. I get
them set up with opportunities to lead, which means they have opportunities to
fail. And so that's, you know, that's. They're gonna
fail. That's a. That's a normal thing. Right. And that
was the second part of my. Of my question. You know, where I made statement,
you know, is if. If they. If they properly plan something and they
do fail, well, that's okay. They're gonna learn from that.
But if we as leaders don't make sure.
And I don't mean. I don't mean in a way is like, okay, you know,
our senior patrol leader, I look at him and I say, you know, Billy.
And that's not his name, but, you know,
did you make a caper chart? Do you have your assignments? Do you have your
schedule? To me, I think it's more of when
they start planning this event, you kind of steer them
in that direction by asking maybe a question,
hey, what meeting are you guys going to do your grub lists
and stuff? That kind of thing. And then it puts it in
their mind that, oh, yeah, we have to do that. And then. And then you
just kind of, you know, you don't push any further than that. Right.
Do you have a form? Yeah, yeah, absolutely. They Use. They have all of
the forms. Menu planning form. Yes, they have the mini
planning form and all of that. It's just. I guess. I guess
it's frustrating. Are there some patrols that use
it and some that don't?
No, they pretty much. They pretty much all use it. We have two patrols that
are, you know, two months into scouting and.
And they have to. They each have a troop guide, and they're doing very well.
The troop guides are keeping them on track.
Well, I'll have to say we describe it.
Go ahead. Sorry. Yeah, we don't have menu planning forms,
and I just can barely ever get our guys to use duty
rosters, but they managed to eat on every campout.
Well, Andre, it's. It's extremely
painful to watch what you're. What you're talking about,
because we're going through the same thing. The last senior patrol leader
was a little young and inexperienced
and tried to point him in the right direction,
and things didn't get done. And it's very frustrating.
But we helped them as much as we could. But then it
was up to them to carry out the plans and do what they wanted
to do, which tended to be nothing, to some extent. We've got
a new senior patrol leader now. There were elections, and he saw.
He was frustrated about the whole thing, and things have changed,
and they're doing. He's doing that. He's doing the change.
Yeah, that's. I mean. Okay, so Tom is right now where you
want to be? Because Tom is seeing the change.
Exactly. As a leader, what can I do without
crossing that. That line that it's got to be in a different place for every
boy, which is really frustrating to me. Do you have junior leader training?
You have. We do have training. Do you think it's effective?
Teenage boys being what teenage boys are, I would say they maybe retain
20 to 30% of it. We did our training, and I
don't think the scoutmasters talked for more than maybe
an hour of it. It was led by spl,
by his aspls, and focused
on things that we needed to, you know, he felt like the leaders
needed to learn. Okay. We just did the new jlt,
and I think you and I. Clark had talked about it. It gives them the
opportunity, the resources to understand what
they need to do, but not the experience. So now
they have to use what they learn to experience the
planning and everything, which there, again, it hurts to watch them
do this. One of the most important things to understand, Andre, is you are by
no means alone. Oh, no, I know
that. I've got three other Assistant Scout masters standing right next to me
with the same. So I'm well aware that
the frustration is not all mine. It's very spread across
the country. Yeah. Not just the troop. Yeah. That times 100,000.
And you're getting an idea. I think what we have to do
sometimes to really stop and ask ourselves what's actually happening
there. We see chaos and craziness and
we see a four hour breakfast and it's distressing and it's
difficult and we feel that in some way we are failing
because the boys just don't have it together. Very good. If you
get on their level and you start to see it through their eyes, they see
something totally different. They may see a well oiled machine
and they may see they're having a whole lot of fun with
their buddies and stuff like that. And there's going to be
a couple of guys in that group who this is rubbing them the wrong
way and they think that they can do it better and they're a
little aggravated with the whole thing. And those guys are your next patrol leaders.
Those guys are the ones who are going to take the reins of things.
I think that a reasonable expectation for us to have
and within the process of youth leaders really
taking a hand in things and really making things happen. I think
the fastest I've ever seen that happen is at
least a year's worth of cajoling and training
and working with them and coaching them and mentoring them
through a process over about a year's time. And then they become really competent.
I've rarely seen it happen sooner than that. Once they
become competent, it's time for them to move on to a more challenging
position. So you always have people who are learning on the job and making mistakes
as the leaders in the troop. It's a normal thing. One of the goals,
my goals when I was a scoutmaster just starting out was to get our
outings planning on a more formal basis,
more of a timeline. And we'd had this decided by then and. And that
took about four years. But this year at the training,
one of our Scouts presented how we do it
to the rest of the patrol leaders council. So now
it's there, now it's working, but it could take forever. I'm going to expand on
Andre's question a little bit. Is there a circumstance where
you do kind of blow the whistle and stop the play? Is there
a set of circumstances that you see Scouts, a patrol
of Scouts or a troop of Scouts where you do actually need to step in
and to make a change. If it falls outside the guide
to safe Scouting, then definitely. So any kind of safety related
thing, you do have to step right in. And anything unsafe,
it's immediate. Right. And what about, I mean, how far into
chaos and disorder do we let the boys descend
before we stop them? I think that almost never happens
with a normal, average group of scouts. They kind
of know what Scouting's about. I think that happens when you get
one or two guys that are leading in the wrong way and
it's actually heading towards mischievousness or worse.
So you have to watch that. But that's not very common.
Most scouts know why they're there.
Normally if they're in charge and they're uniformed
and they're doing scouting, they're tying knots, they're camping
normally, they're inside the bounds of
kind of where you want them to be. Let me ask you a question.
Did you always feel that way or was there a point in
being a scoutmaster early on where it really bothered you?
Actually, for me mostly, no, there really wasn't a
point. It still bothers me and
I've got to bite my tongue. I'm right there with you, Tom and Andre.
It still is a difficult thing to watch,
isn't it? Watch these guys build a campfire. It's just painful.
Andre, is this helping at all? Yeah,
absolutely. You guys are giving me lots of things to think about.
You know, maybe, you know, maybe I'm looking at this the wrong way and spend
a lot more time closely observing them and trying to see
things, you know, from their point of view and seeing
are they having fun rather than, you know,
you know, is this, is this efficient? Is this the way it's supposed
to be? Are they doing it the way they want to do it and is
it happening? Yeah. Our winter camping is snow. And so
that's an instance where some of the planning is the adults participate
in. Like you really have to have enough food, you have to have fuel.
That's a safety issue for that.
But we still do as much as possible, have the boys
do as much as possible. And Andre, let me, let me mention that while
he's talking about that, the best way to get by that is to, is to
encourage them, through your leadership, to put themselves in a
position where they're going to need that training. And that's camping
in the snow, that's canoeing, that's backpacking, that's something
like that, where they, they are going
to have to make some plans. I think, I think you're right. Larry? I think
when they have to do something that is really physically challenging, and I think backpacking
is a good, a good example. If you're not prepared to go backpacking the right
way, you just have a miserable time. It may not be dangerous or anything
like that. It's just kind of miserable. That kind of an intense challenge often shakes
them out a little bit. Hey, Andre, are you doing stuff like that? Are y'
all backpacking? Well, they, they did do a canoe trip last year. We did it.
They did a 30 miler. How'd you feel about that event?
It was seamless. I mean, it was a great event. I think
it took them away, you know, they're more than a hundred yards from the car,
you know, and I think, I think that sometimes changes the mentality,
a different mode of thinking. So maybe you need a little bit
more of that to challenge. To me, it seems like once they get out and
away from that, you know, it does, it does something to their, to their,
their outlook on things. When the alternative is being miserable,
they will usually find a way not to be miserable. Doesn't,
Doesn't a lot of this fall under the. Ask lots and lots
of questions beforehand and kind of kind of
work them through this so that it looks like it's coming from them.
That's kind of what I was thinking I needed to be doing, was just asking
a lot of questions and putting the thought in their mind that, oh, yeah,
we need to do that. No, we didn't do this. You know,
there was another thing that I have adopted once
I heard Larry say it. What it's turned into is a very quick way for
me to be able to talk to my youth leaders briefly and
to put them back on track. Larry, what's the mission
of all the youth leaders in a scout troop? Lead, train, and inspire
Scouts to achieve first class rank. I'm using that too.
Uh oh, I've got them inculcated with that now. And when
they're headed off the rails, when I see the chaos coming on and I see
that they're going to miss out on something, I can very quietly ask
them what their mission is, and it puts them right back on the track.
If they don't get it right off, I ask them questions. How are they
achieving that mission right now? Helps them think their way through. So I
really don't tell them anything. I just ask them enough questions to get them to
discover for themselves what they should be up to.
I'm glad to see that I'm kind of thinking along the correct
Line mentoring and asking questions. That's your job. And particularly
to the older Scouts. One of my favorite questions is to my older
Scouts is, what's going on right
now? You know, if I ask them what's happening right now, that is usually
an indication that something should be happening that isn't.
Say, look, I don't want to take this over. I want you to lead those
guys. Look at those little huibles over there. You know, how are they getting there?
And ask them that. You know, just kind of challenge them with that. Say,
those guys are yours. That's their job. Do you go about that any differently tomorrow?
That's the way I'm trying to do it. And it works
sometimes, and then again, it doesn't. Like I said, the new senior patrol
leader has been frustrated with the way things were
going, and he has started engaging
the patrol leaders and just the members at
large. Whenever you get frustrated like that,
grab one or two of the little guys and open their books and say,
hey, you know, what do you need from second class here? And they go,
well, I need this, this, and this. Say, have you talked to your patrol leader?
We have one meeting a month is a patrol meeting, and that's not
at the norm. You know, they've got to arrange where that is. And so
the patrol leader has no choice but to find a place
and run a meeting. You know, with the edge requirement
in the. Was it life requirement.
Now, that gives them, most of them, plenty of opportunity
to turn around and give back to the younger Scouts.
And it's a requirement, so,
you know, they've got to do it at least once.
I think there's a lot of good advice there, guys, and some real good
thoughts. Andre, is there. Is there anything else we can do for you? Any other
questions we can answer for you at this point? Probably go on for five
or ten more sessions, so probably not want to get into that.
I would like to say to everybody for taking the
time to discuss this with me and sharing some of your advice and
your experience. You've really given me a lot to think about and
even affirm some of the things I'm doing right.
Maybe some of the things I need to relook. And I really do
appreciate your time. Well, we really appreciate you taking the time to talk
with us, Andrew. Before Andre goes, his and Larry's definition
of winter camping is different from yours and mine.
Winter camping is when it. When it might dip down into the 30s or something,
right? We just went through 18. One of our snow camping
trips. It got up to 55 up in the snow. It was
lovely and it was colder back where we live. I'm not
even going to mess with you guys. It was,
you know, mid-70s today, and that's, you know, normal for
this time of year. I went to school in Houston, so I've.
I'm familiar with that kind of weather. Okay, exactly.
Talking about, hang in with these guys, you and your
leaders. It's. It's tough sometimes, and it can
happen and you will know it when it does.
So it sounds like he's. He's had glimpses of it. He is
getting glimpses of it through some of the camping trips we was talking about.
We had a lot of events that go, you know,
really well, and then there's just train wrecks. So,
you know, I think it's there. It's just not always there, apparently.
Keep having train wrecks because that means they're doing it well.
It absolutely means that the adults aren't stepping in to save them every other time.
Yeah. I always tell visiting Cub parents that if it looks like
the meeting's being run by amateurs, then it's a Scout meeting and
it's being done. Right. Well, thanks again, Andre. Thank you, guys.
Well, listen, we've gone a bit over. Have we left anything out
or is there anything else that anybody wanted to hear? You have a new granddaughter.
I've been trying not to let that get out. I saw the picture.
Congratulations. I appreciate the congratulations. Thanks, fellas,
for helping us out again with the Scoutmaster panel discussion.
We look forward to talking to you again soon. Thanks a lot, Tom. You're welcome,
Clark. Good night. And Larry, thank you. You're welcome, Clark.
Walter, it's been a pleasure. Is it
dark in Silicon Valley now? The sun has gone down. I can see the lights
heading down the highway. All right, well, thanks again, gentlemen,
and we'll talk to you again soon. Good night. Night. Good night.
Well, thanks once again for listening to the Scott Master podcast. Here's how
you can keep in touch. First, you can read the scoutmaster blog@scoutmastercg.com
there you can subscribe to receive updates by email.
You can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on itunes.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device through Stitcher
Smart Radio. You can get details about that@stitcher.com
youm can call and leave a voicemail comment or question at
this number, 484 734-0002.
You can experience the wonders of ScoutMasterCG.com for the
vast panorama of social media outlets that's right. You can follow us at Scoutmaster Blog
on Facebook, tweet ScoutMasterCG on Twitter,
and for admittance to the exclusive Scoutmaster CG Circle
search for Scoutmaster CG on Google.
Hey, if you don't face, you don't face tweet and you don't plus
that's okay, bunky. You can email me Clark Green with
your comments and questions and wild ideas@scoutmastercgorizon.net
the Scoutmaster Blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy
Scouts of America. No, it's just me talking into a microphone, trying to lend a
hand to Scout leaders and perhaps have a little bit of fun along.
Before we leave you today, we're going to hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden
Powell. Sir Robert Good luck to you and good champion.
Why, thank you, sir. Until next time.